[Music]
this morning as many americans get ready
to return to the workplace or school
they may realize their skin is not quite
ready to return with them and so they're
looking to improve things 47 percent of
consumers experimented with new skin
care products during the pandemic and
that's in part due to the thousands of
social media influencers who promote
products from toners to cleansers to
their millions of followers and the
skincare business is expected to get
even bigger to explode in the years
ahead it's already a 131 billion dollar
global industry expected to grow 38
by 2025 so to put all of that into
perspective and to help us sort through
it we're joined now by dermatologist
jeannie down at janine downey uh dr
downey thank you for being here thank
you it's a confusing time for all of us
when it comes to skincare
because if you were working from home
maybe you weren't you know doing what
you used to do and now you're back in
the office maybe
what do you do to get back on your
routine okay so the first thing is you
want to just take it slowly so a lot of
people weren't even you know doing
anything so at least use a moisturizer
every single day regardless of whether
your skin's oily dry or combination or
sensitive and then put sunscreen on
every day so that's a sunscreen with an
spf 30.
rain or shine doesn't matter if you're
still home sometimes uh we as humans we
react to indoor lighting outdoor
lighting the blue light from the phone
computer from the apple watch from the
ipad all of it so everybody wants
sunscreen everyone everyone needs
sunscreen all the time so that skin of
color um when i tell my patients all the
time now that the masks are coming
coming off we're detecting all kinds of
skin cancers that have been there for
the past year or year and a half with
the pandemic so skin of color needs to
wear sunblock also every single day and
reapply it and then your pore size will
stay smaller your get less wrinkles and
your skin will be more even and glowing
so you'll look younger longer so there's
that
you mentioned the mask and i know
everybody's dealt with this um shall we
say we all feel like we're teenagers all
over again with some mask knee going on
exactly so i say treat your mask like
you treat your underwear don't throw it
around the place i i don't know what
what is this some people what is this
flag this is called the chest
nephew's listening so you pull your
underwear up properly pull your mask up
properly and then wash it if you're
using a reusable mesh wash it every day
and for disposable masks they're called
disposable because you're supposed to
throw them away at the end of the day
and if you're getting a lot of friction
from the mask dana to your point then
you might want to change your mask and
try a different fabric try something
different there's a lot out there right
i was fascinated to learn that we've
been washing our faces incorrectly it's
like don't wash your face at all
remember elizabeth warren said she
doesn't walk yeah she doesn't wash or
like it's just like a splash of water um
i was the guy who was like scrubbing
with like all sorts of scrubs and like
loofahs on my face and is that not how
you're supposed to well he does so my
husband and my daughter
my husband and my daughter say i'm bossy
so i want a mild to a moderate amount of
pressure with a wash cloth that you
change once every two to three days for
twice a day at a bare minimum so you
need to from your hairline down to the
base here if you're breaking out with
acne or men have hair bumps down here
then perhaps they're including their
neck unit as well but not scrubbing like
you're scrubbing a pot blade you don't
want your face to look like a pop two
notes from like a pod you know what i'm
saying so that's very important but i'm
very very bossy with the face washing
and like i said two times a day thank
you we don't have any more time to get
into this but we will discuss more
skincare routines i'm very worried about
vlad right now
thank you thank you thank you for having
me